bonjour je m'appelle l'admr yvan
bienvenue merci nous retrouver dans
cette autre édition d' espace autochtone
en direct aujourd'hui nous allons
plonger je dirais dans le monde de
l'éducation
avec quatre invités et là je vous dis
tout de suite les quatre est en fait
c'est un peu un hasard sont tous de
l'université du québec à montréal ça
aurait pu être autrement mais ça n'a pas
été le cas alors nous allons plonger à
l'université du québec à montréal avec
évidemment notre chroniqueuse il avait
piqué rebonjour isabelle oui parce que
vous aussi vous êtes de l'uqam vous êtes
chargé de cours à louis-ii 8 août a fait
elle pour vous donner d'ailleurs je
donne deux courts gouvernance
autochtones au féminin et l'autre avec
le rhin je donne des trucs sans au monde
autochtone d'accord laurent jérôme vous
vous êtes professeur à l'uqam et là
votre définition tâche est très longue
alors je vais vous laisser nous le dire
qu'est ce que vous faites
plusieurs bonjour merci pour
l'invitation plusieurs choses mais entre
autres co responsable des programmes
d'études autochtone à l'uqam et
directeur de la revue recherches
canadiennes au québec
voilà entre autres a donc nous allons
parler avec vous de décolonisation du
monde de l'éducation également parmi nos
invités maïlys flamand maylis bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes une jeune
étudiante à du cac mais vous n'êtes pas
une jeune étudiante vous avez quand même
vous vous êtes promenés dans le réseau
de l'éducation vous avez étudié à
plusieurs endroits oui pas mal à
plusieurs à plusieurs universités au
québec entre autres entre autres yuste
laval manière stricte ok c'est
intéressant on va pouvoir voir on va
pouvoir comparer également comment ça se
passe dans les universités et puis marie
christine petit quizz bonjour marie
christine alors vous aussi vous êtes
étudiante à l'uqam donc tout le monde
est à l'uqam et puis vous êtes la
présidente du cercle des premières
nations de l'université du québec à
montréal
oui voilà
alors on va plonger tout de suite dans
notre sujet des colonisés le monde de
l'éducation
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous et
je vais commencer par maylis pour moi ça
commence par sensibiliser les étudiants
c'est à notre réalité en tant que
docteur c'est dans les classes parfois
dispo évidente parler notre culture puis
tout fait que celles qui portent un
regard différent par rapport à ce qu'on
fait c'est à nous aussi de se présenter
puis de toutes façons d'économiser je
trouve même même chose pour les
professeurs aussi dans les immensités
pas tout le monde qui savent eux notre
réalité qui s'apprend et ouais c'est
important de la porter dans les
esturgeons ok on va tantôt savoir
comment vous le faites mais d'abord je
pose la même question à vous monsieur
jérôme oui mais pour moi c'est sûr que
c'est en tant qu' il ya deux avenues
pour cette cette réponse on a
effectivement beaucoup de tâches en tant
qu' en tant que professeur dont il ya la
pratique de l'enseignement comme comme
les gens le savent les gens qui me
connaissent et les auditeurs qu'ils
m'entendent je ne suis pas autochtone
donc c'est déjà premièrement reconnaître
son son bagage dans les courges c'est
comme ça que souvent je commence mes
cours je veux dire j'assume le fait
d'être un homme blanc anthropologue et
puis la pire des le pire des défauts
comme je le répète souvent c'est en plus
de sa dette français sur les questions
autochtones donc mais c'est de
reconnaître vraiment ce bagage et
d'amener vraiment les expertises au sein
de la salle de classe alors ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire invité des
conférenciers des experts autochtone
pour donner leur point de vue sur les
thèmes qui sont abordés qui sont abordés
en classe
donc ça c'est la pratique de
l'enseignement et on a une
responsabilité aussi en termes de
services à la collectivité
et là c'est un gros du travail c'est
d'amener les institutions à considérer
une transformation radicale de la
manière d'envisager l'éducation en se
basant sur les expertises autochtones
quand vous dites les institutions ce ne
sont pas que les institutions
universitaires ou collégiales ou
même les écoles secondaires il ya
beaucoup de travail formidable qui est
fait dans les écoles secondaires dans
les écoles primaires dans les cégeps
on s'est rencontré avec isabelle au
musée de la civilisation donc c'est les
institutions culturelles et muséal
également qu'il ya un rôle boulic à sion
également important donc la
décolonisation effectivement touche
touche l'ensemble des institutions
culturelles responsable de transmettre
des savoirs
oui d'ailleurs je voulais en parler tout
de suite en fait parce que je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant c'est jeannette
marques qui travaillent énormément dans
le cadre de cette décolonisation là en
faisant de la formation en donnant de la
formation à l'extérieur du monde
universitaire du monde scolaire en
allant dans les entreprises
et je pense qu'ils ont développé là-bas
vraiment une expertise pour aller
expliquer le monde autochtone à des gens
qui ne le sont pas il fait vraiment un
travail colossal à ce niveau là isabelle
la même question pour vous des colonisés
l'éducation ben je dirais que dans mon
corps moi j'ai suivi le certificat en
études autochtones à l'université laval
il ya déjà 20 ans et je n'avais aucun
professeur autochtone dans toute ma
formation quand même
maintenant on commence à en voir et
pouvoir des enseignants déchargés cours
autochtone parfois il faut un peu se
serait pas passé les critères mais je
dirais plutôt reconnaître le fait que
ces enseignants autochtones l'homme même
si ils ont seulement un bac ou un
diplôme de deuxième cycle
normalement on demande une maîtrise mais
ils ont quand même l'expérience d'être
autochtone d'avoir vécu dans des
communautés d'avoir travaillé dans des
organisations autochtones et cette
reconnaissance là pour moi ça fait aussi
partie de la décolonisation de
l'éducation est bon ça fait quand même
quelques années que j'enseigne à l'uqam
mais j'ai aussi enseigné aux 6-12 ans à
l'université saint paul qui est une
université sort de l'université d'ottawa
bien sûr non bio ça fait vraiment
longtemps j'étais un fan mama vingtaine
et là aussi on permettait donc cette
ouverture là parce qu'on reconnaissait
l'expérience autochtone là perso sfr
donc ça pour moi c'est déjà un plus et
je pense que les étudiants accueil ça
avec beaucoup d'intérêt le fait d'être
d'automne on est peut-être capable de
donner des exemples plus concrets donc
ce côté là et après c'est non mais jeudi
à 12 ans parce que déjà l'université
saint paul était presque en avance sur
son temps en allant de l'humain
absolument c'était sûrement parmi les
universités à le faire une des premières
en tout cas pas comment ça se passe dans
le reste du pays ailleurs au pays
si on regarde en colombie-britannique
enfin je connais pas l'expérience mais
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya 12 years
certaines certaines universités dans
l'ouest canadien où on oublie chaque
étudiant qui se présentent à n'importe
quel bac dans n'importe quel domaine de
suivre au moins un cours d'introduction
ou aux études autochtones ou aux
affaires autochtones
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressant à
leiria oh oui quelle belle expérience
marie-christine ça fait trois ans vous
êtes à l'uqam oui vous avez eu divers
professeurs est ce que on peut on peut
en parler entre les professeurs
autochtones et non autochtones avez vous
eu des professeurs autochtone d'ailleurs
du cab
oui ben en fait j'ai eu isabelle picard
oui car l'une des deux heures pour les
deux pour le même court en fait je suis
en train de faire la concentration de
ces détecteurs dans le cas de mon bac en
sciences politiques et j'ai suivi le
cours d'introduction monde autochtone
win avec isabelle et caroline mais j'ai
aussi fait le cours de ferme autochtones
du québec des bailleurs jeu avec
caroline auquel l'auteur professeur d'un
autochtone oui oui
caroline qui a commencé ici à espace
autochtone aussi qui a été une des
créatrices d'espèces autochtones foule
mentionné et qui est maintenant à l'uqam
et mais quand vous quand vous comparez
l'enseignement que vous avez reçu entre
les professeurs autochtones et non
autochtones
est-ce que vous il ya plein de choses
que vous auriez voulu voir différents de
la part des profs non autochtone dans
leur façon de vous enseigner dans leur
façon de communiquer avec vous je sais
pas peut-être avoir un peu plus
d'assurance
dans le sens qu'elle est souvent les
profs non autochtone que j'avais mes
spots est comme dans dans la classe qui
me regardait comme du coin de l'oeil
comme s'il cherchait une certaine
validation à s'assurer que qu'est ce
qu'ils disent oui et oui je parle pas de
leurs angles mais non ça vous est pas
arrivé non pas de sept pas de cette
manière mais c'est sûr que c'est
beaucoup de pression pour les
professeurs de chargés de cours tout
personnel enseignant puisqu'on a d'un
côté des recommandations notamment de la
commission vérité réconciliation qui
demande à inclure dans l'enseignement de
plus besoin de plus en plus de contenu
autochtone oui donc ça dépend de son
bagasse est pas tout le monde qui est
capable de le faire et ça arrive
effectivement c'est souvent ça a été
documentée que des enseignants soient
parfois passer certains de leurs
thématiques de leur sujet de la manière
d'en parler et qui apostrophe dans le
court sachant qu'il ya des étudiants
autochtones dans le court essaye d'avoir
un appui ou de demander peut-être une
validation de ce qu'ils sont en train de
dire dans la salle de classe qui peut
mettre mal à l'aise effectivement ce
étudiants autochtones mais comment est
ce qu ils se sont préparés à ça alors
c'est un dvd enjeu majeur actuellement
dans le monde de l'éducation c'est les
formations du personnel du personnel
enseignant et plus largement des
employés des universités mais
particulièrement pour le personnel
enseignant il ya beaucoup de réflexions
qui sont réalisés actuellement pour
essayer d'encourager les enseignants à
se former aux réalités autochtones à se
former qui va les femmes autochtones
oui d'accord mais est-ce que c'est
l'université qui leur offrent ces
formations est ce que c'est aux
professeurs de se débrouiller tout seul
ce tintin grande question sa démesure
dans l'ensemble les universités
justement sont aujourd'hui au pied du
mur on l'a mentionné un peu il ya des
expériences diverses et variées au
québec mais également au canada
on peut sans trop se tromper dire que le
reste du canada et bien en avant sur sur
le québec est qu'au québec on a des
universités quand même en avance sur
d'autres comme concordia l'uqac leucate
sont des universités qui fondent et du
travail formidable en termes de
formation mais aussi de prise en compte
des réalités autochtones dans les
manières d'enseigner
oui c'est cela on a un retard assez
importante dans les universités
francophones dont l'uqam l'université de
montréal on a beaucoup de travail à
faire c'est intéressant de faire la
comparaison est justement cette semaine
concordia publiait une nouvelle où on
parle de d'une nomination la directrice
principale des orientations autochtones
qui vient d'être nommé dans ce poste là
mais il ya aussi une directrice de la
décolonisation des programmes d'études
et de la pédagogie est ce qu'on est prêt
de sa de ce genre de poste à l'uqam par
exemple au marie-christine on veut vous
entendre marie christine là dessus je
tends d'illustrer la whey commencé à ce
sujet mais on n'est pas prêt mais pas
prétendre ne pas prévoir donc peu de
l'université francophone il ya des
mesures sont prises il ya des comités
décolonisation
l'université de montréal a fait un
travail formidable avec des
consultations beaucoup de consultations
avec différents représentants des
premières nations et des inuits et
concordia évidemment l'uqam est en train
de je dirais de se réveiller d'essayer
de rattraper de rattraper son retard à
son retard à différents niveaux
il ya différentes actions qui ont été
pressés dernière ces dernières années
mais ça prend une volonté plus qu'une
volonté de l'institution c'est beaucoup
et sans le constate en documentant c'est
beaucoup d'une volonté d'individus c'est
des individus dans les institutions qui
doivent être concernées motivé et
dégager le temps pour faire avancer ce
dossier là s'il n'y a pas ces personnes
là dans les dents les institutions qui
désirent vraiment ardemment créer des
partenariats avec les milieux autochtone
c'est sûr que les dossiers vont être mis
sur la glace
est ce que le désir il est là isabelle
vous le voyez ou pas je le vois oui à
certains niveaux
effectivement mais c'est un l'aube et
qu'on doit faire que de manière
constante en tant qu'autochtones et à
tous les niveaux et un moment donné on
n'est pas des pieuvres non plus et comme
ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain il
faut faire ça on ne le support de
certains professeurs notamment je sais
que l'on travaille beaucoup pour
décoloniser disons l'uqam puis à c y et
d'améliorer les programmes en phase est
bon l'expérience pour les autochtones
mais pour les non autochtones aussi bien
sûr donc il ya tout ce côté là où l'on
parle beaucoup des autochtones jusqu'à
présent mais le côté connaissance
j'enseigne un cours d'introduction au
monde autochtone et dans ma classe j'ai
99 pour sa dinde allochtone qui sont
intéressés par le court ça c'est
extrêmement intéressant pour nous de
voir si c'est motivant on travaille pas
pour rien parce qu'il ya quelques années
moi quand je faisais mon certificat ces
bourses y avait 20 personnes dans la
classe donc il y avait vraiment une
importante évolution
donc c'est pas égal je donne à tous les
niveaux pour que tout le monde est ce
que le cercle des premières nations
c'est son boulot aussi c'est ça ta
jouissent et d'accueillir parce que
c'est ça le but 1 du cercle c'est
accueillir les étudiants autochtones qui
arrivent de partout qui viennent étudier
dans ce cas là à l'uqam mais est-ce que
c'est aussi pour conscientiser les profs
les autres étudiants comment ça se passe
marie curie mais justement le stade de
trémeur nation sa mission ce peut se
diviser entre volets le premier c'est de
soutenir vraiment les étudiants
autochtones qui arrivent des communautés
pour les aider à mieux s'adapter non
seulement la vie universitaire c'est la
vie urbaine
la deuxième mission c'est vraiment de
promouvoir les cultures autochtones donc
dans le fond le sac de farine à sion
s'est crue a été créée en 1990 après la
crise d'oka quand même donc c'était on a
trouvé le bon moment pour le mettre sur
pied une démission c'est un peu de
promouvoir comme une image plus positive
de l'autochtone puis le de la dernière
c'est vraiment d'établir des liens
d'amitié et de coopération entre les
étudiants allochtones et autochtones mal
qu est ce que ça fonctionne est ce que
ça marche bien
moi je pense que oui ben je sais pas
dans le sens que dans les cours que je
suis en ce moment dans la concentration
d'études autochtone je les entend
discuter justement l'autre jour on
parlait de décolonisation qui j'étais
quand même juste ça faisait du bien dans
mon petit cas d j'avais de l'espoir et
d'espoir pour la mère donc parce que les
étudiants qui suivent le court et quand
on arrive justement au sujet de la
décolonisation les étudiants jeunes
autochtones comment est-ce qu'ils
réagissent qu'est ce qu'ils disent mais
c'est un peu ce jeu là c'est bien
réfléchir ce matin puis dans mon cours
on a quoi 81,3 entreprises étudiants
quand même c'est un gros court mais les
gens arrivent avec des connaissances
tellement différente c'est comme si on
prenait un cours de français
il y en a qui savent pas parler français
puis d'autres qui vient juste pour finir
leurs gamins alors fou toujours toujours
ajusté ça c'est vraiment pas évident et
avant d'arriver vraiment à pouvoir avoir
une conversation sur la réconciliation
ou encore mieux la décolonisation ça va
être vraiment la fin du cours parce que
il ya plein de choses qui doivent être
vus c'est un vin qui ne sont pas vus par
les étudiants au cégep à l'université
ou est ce qu'il faut vraiment commencer
à la base
maintenant je sens une ouverture des
étudiants quand on a ces discussions là
vraiment que je n'ai pas vu précédemment
de12 ans peut-être quand j'étais dans
une autre université
donc il ya avec l'actualité ou si on est
plus présent un peu partout on sait en
temps je pense que les réalistes ont
davantage connue donc une belle brise
oui maylis vous vous êtes promenés entre
plusieurs universités
c'était quoi la différence comment ça
s'est passé quand vous étiez donc vous
êtes passé par laval entre autres par
chicoutimi un oui et comment ça s'est
passé d'une université à l'autre mais
chez que moi j'ai commencé à
l'université laval
j'avais commencé un back and design
graphique mais je n'ai jamais poursuivi
là vous quittiez à ce moment-là manouane
et va directement mais en fait je n'ai
de finir mon bon c'est j'ai mon cégep
points oui à quel endroit à tour via ok
donc la manouane trois-rivières laval
chicoutimi puis ensuite trois rivières
mais j'ai abandonné mes cours en ce
moment le plein ce qui a manqué à trois
rivières par exemple comment ça s'est
passé comment on est accueilli quand on
est autochtone est ce que il y à des
services est ce qu'on sent dans des
cours qu'on connaît les autochtones
qu'on accueille parce que j'imagine qu'à
trois rivières y en a plusieurs l'a1
c'est normal beaucoup d étudiants qui
quittent les communauté attikamek entre
autres passe par trois rivières matteau
revient quand j'ai commencé le cégep
c'était plus ou moins intégré fait qu'il
n'y avait pas encore à ce moment là une
agente de liaison pour les autochtones
justement ça a été intégré deux ou trois
ans après que j'ai été admis et ça fait
pas si longtemps que ça on se marie
christine vous êtes passé par trois
rivières aussi oui c'est ça en fait j'ai
commencé mon cheminement peu secondaire
avec un dec à double dec en fait en arts
visuels et sciences humaines
c'est déjà de trois verres oui mais je
n'ai pas terminé ma formation
2 vous avez quitté trois-rivières
bon je veux pas savoir exactement les
raisons mais je veux dire est ce que est
ce que vous vous sentiez accueillis ou
au contraire vous vous sentiez tellement
à l'écart que vous avez choisi autre
chose ben non en fait c'est j'ai terminé
mon monde est qu en arts visuels ou
celle de tourbières que j'avais envie
d'aller ailleurs pour l'université ok ok
excellent moi je te ressaisir de trois
heures entre 2009 et 2012
oui ça m'a pris peut-être environ j'ai
commencé à me dire et plus ça ma
troisième année où est ce que je suis
devenu en fait représentants de
programmes à l'association générale
étudiante balaj acteurs
enfin en 2012 cependant de tout en le
voyant
non en fait le jeu blanc pour les
étudiants qu'en disait jeudi en ce sens
mais à cause de ça j'ai quand même pu
négliger beaucoup mais qu à d'accord
mais
mais l'agent de liaison lui est arrivé
quand et où elle est arrivée à quel
moment et de prayssas n'était pas encore
l'heure quand j étais qui est non mais
ce sera en fait c'est le cégep
finalement j'avais dû quitter parce que
je n'avais pas réussi le jeu de contreur
donc faire je réussisse comme 50% de mes
crédits pour poursuivre mes études mais
est ce que le fait qu'ils aient eu une
agente de liaison par la suite ça a
changé les choses pour les étudiants
autochtones qui sont arrivés après dans
ce cégep la rejetant que oui parce
qu'elle a à l'organiser justement des
activités pour les autochtones et des
sorties culturelles tu es dans les
autres villes aussi ça nous a permis
aussi d'être ses délires tisser des
liens entre ses déliés weppes et mieux
s'intégrer aussi pour ces gens parce que
c'est pas évident sortie de sa
communauté puis étudier ailleurs c est
ce que dans les cégeps on est on est au
même niveau dans les universités quand
il est question de décoloniser
sion de de l'éducation de l'enseignement
le cégep font un gros travail la
fédération des cégeps pour entamer une
grosse réflexion justement sur la
décolonisation à montréal il ya
l'exemple du collège ahuntsic aussi wii
qui est très très actif mais encore là
comme je vous mentionne cesser une
personne une équipe de personnes qui
portent le dossier et qui le pousse
l'institution l'appui ou l'appui pas
dans ce cas-là l'institution l'appui
donc ce qui est variable
évidemment les gens qui sont dans cette
institution et la manière dont les
responsables qui sont à la tête de
l'institution vont accorder ou non le
temps et les ressources pour accéder aux
recommandations et aux appels à l'action
de ces personnes-là de ces équipes là
dans les institutions mais il ya un gros
travail qui est fait au niveau de ses
gps et je crois très important
puis elle eu évidemment kiuna qui je
pense que j'allais fallait absolument
souligner aussi le l'exemple qui ont
cessé ou est-ce que j'ai fini par
terminer mes études collégiales en 2010
est donc juste avoir pareil car oui
alors qu'il n'en avait expliqué qui est
donc un cégep pas seulement d'ailleurs
pour les autochtones parce que j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des non autochtones qui
avait gradué acquis au nas qui est
franchement une belle réussite quand on
sait que les non autochtones sont aussi
intéressés à y étudier donc toi est ce
que tu es allé maëlys je dis toi
maintenant championne non j'ai pas pu
tout jackie o n'y avait pas vraiment ce
que je voulais team double étudiants
n'ont fait et il avait besoin ce moment
là il y avait juste sciences humaines
louis m'appelle plus l'hôte beaucoup de
programmes à ce moment le fait que je me
suis plus diriger vers le cégep de trois
rivières
oui mais si tu avais eu le choix si par
exemple il y aurait eu la formation qui
voulait avoir est ce que tu aurais
choisi kinois oui c'est sûr le sait je
pense aujourd'hui je me dis j'aurais dû
étudier acquis aux notes c'est ça la
téléphonie est ce qu est ce que tu
aurais eu de plus à ton avis mais je
pense que ça m'aurait permis aussi de me
reconnecter à ma culture est pas évident
si étudier dans les universités pitt ou
alors que tille - présence autochtone
c'est moi j'ai suivi un certificat
notamment soirée dès cet automne à
l'uqac
mais justement on peut juste des
étudiants autochtones de partout au
québec
il y avait juste 2 allochtone
affecteront les intégrer avec nous fait
que ce téléphone tire pas mal de cette
santé l'emploi depuis le travail
d'équipé les professeurs aussi qu'ils
étaient vraiment compréhensible nous qui
vous les gens vont vraiment nous
enseigner c'est est-ce que c'était des
profs autochtone qui enseignait
allochtone tous adoptent tous non
autochtone oui ok mais il avait ce set
cette ouverture l'enfant oui oui il
avait un bagage justement autres et ils
ont travaillé dans les communautés fait
qu'il savait c'est qu'il savait comment
nous enseigner oui oui oui oui on
regarde ce qui se fait à du cam on
parlait aussi de l'université de
montréal il ya les universités
francophones entre vous est ce que tous
ceux qui ont un intérêt justement pour
le monde autochtone et pour les études
autochtones est ce que vous avez des
liens entre vous est ce qu'il ya des
échanges qui se font
on a plusieurs bien évidemment malien on
a plusieurs liens de collaboration que
ce soit en enseignement dans le domaine
de la recherche et plusieurs équipes de
recherche l'agencé sur le fait que
recherche et enseignement sont liés il
faut aussi penser à décoloniser les
recherches lui on n'arrivera pas à
décoloniser l'enseignement sans
décoloniser les recherches c'est bon
dans les recherches et beaucoup de
chercheurs aussi autochtone
donc on essaie de valoriser à
l'intérieur des cours donc ça c'est
vraiment important mais on travaille on
travaille souvent ensemble je dirais que
on travaille aussi à l'intérieur la
liane au niveau du réseau d étude de
l'université du québec une table de
travail sur les réalités autochtones qui
s'est formé et qui est composée de
personnes représentant diverses
institutions du réseau d une q et qui
travaille aussi à établir des priorités
en matière de décolonisation de
l'enseignement de l'éducation dans les
différentes composantes du réseau d uc
eu donc je pense que de toute façon
c'est un travail d'équipé
c'est impossible de travailler en silo
la contrepartie de ça on a mentionné
rapidement je passe vous le sentez je
suis sûr que oui c'est ken sur
sollicitation des personnes des autres
des autochtones dans les processus de
décolonisation
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'on toutes
les institutions en même temps veulent
s'inscrire dans ce mouvement là et c'est
de le faire bien
je pense que tout le monde vraiment cet
objectif de le faire bien donc en
collaboration partenariat avec des
représentants autochtones
oui mais on va chercher tout le monde va
chercher les mêmes représentants ce qui
fait que comme tout le monde sur sa
liste et donc là c'est un autre problème
ça amène un autre problème dont il faut
tenir compte c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut vraiment pas multiplier les
actions et se regrouper pour travailler
ensemble à dans ce processus là et
essayer de dépasser alors ça c'est pas
évident d'essayer de dépasser
l'appartenance institutionnels
l'appartenance à l'université on est
tous de l'uqam ici mais je pense que
toutes les personnes qui sont ici ont
vite dépassé cette appartenance à l'uqam
et de travail et plus globalement sur
l'enseignement l'éducation universitaire
l'éducation secondaire donc je pense que
cet ensemble à avoir parce que sinon on
s'en sortira pas
d'ailleurs et là je reviens avec vous en
tant qu'étudiante lecerf qu'est ce que
c'est la même chose est-ce que vous
collaborez avec d'autres universités
bah oui en fait
l'année dernière on collaborait beaucoup
avec le salon bois t il à sarko coiffier
à l'université de montréal
oui c'est plus ou moins vrai cette année
je sais pas trop ce qui se passe avec la
main
et quel genre de collaboration vous
aviez vite de même on organisait mettons
des conférences on évitait des
conférences et puis on splitté mais on
disait on divisait les coûts entre nous
et l'autre l'autre cercle totalement
d'accord l'instant les étudiants
autochtones se retrouvait aussi un
ensemble à ce moment là parce que la
ville est grande quand même mais en même
temps les étudiants dans chacune des
universités
ça monte à quoi l'univers comme à l'uqam
par exemple vous avez à peu près combien
d'étudiants autochtones est ce qu on
sait à peu près combien sont inscrits
mois le dernier chiffre que j'avais en
date de l'année dernière
most s 140 utilisé en 1948 à l'uqam à
l'uqam ouais ok d'accord venus d'un peu
partout la excluant tous les campus oui
c'est ça en deçà des objectifs
d'ailleurs dû du groupe de travail
commun mis en place à l'uqam c'était
d'essayer d'identifier des étudiants
autochtones oui dans toutes les
universités il ya un travail qui est
fait là dessus mais c'est très difficile
de recenser des étudiants tokten parce
que d'une part tout le monde ne
s'identifient pas quand
quand elles arrivent à l'université pour
différentes raisons ça ça a été
documentée par la recherche tout
simplement des étudiants autochtones qui
n'ont pas envie d'être identifiée en
tant qu autochtone à l'université qui
ont envie de continuer leur chemin en
tant qu'étudiant que n'ont ils pas envie
d'être étiqueté ça a été documentée
notamment dans l'hôtellerie this
compagnie
un bac catégoriser oui mais c'est pour
différentes raisons et les conséquences
des stigmates historique donc on n'a pas
envie de revivre ce raciste qu'on a
probablement connu ailleurs et on n'a
pas envie d'être sur sa liste et aussi
des comme partagé la tête roma dans la
classe pour qu'elle ait un problème en
tant qu'étudiant autochtone j'ai 20 ans
je me souviens quand je faisais mon
certificat d'études autochtone on était
quelques autochtones dans la salle
jonathan l'année et elle à l'époque
louis carles picard si oui nous l'a
également qu'on connaît bien
maya molène également et est souvent les
professeurs nous tendait le micro en
disant mais vous c'est qu'est ce que
vous en pensez votre réalité et on est
là et on a 19 20 ans et si on n'est pas
toujours à l'aise de partager on est en
train aussi de se faire notre bilan
prédication oui parce que même si on est
autochtone au primaire et au secondaire
on n'apprend pas notre histoire notre
culture on il faut vraiment travailler
nous mêmes avec la voire des années en
lisant banshee terrain et on n'a pas
nécessairement envie tout le temps de
partager ce qu'on vit ou ce qui se vit
dans notre communauté on ne t'entraînes
procédé ne trouve également de gérer
mais reste intéressant si j'ai
l'impression que ça se poursuit donc
cette façon de faire comment pour elle a
transformé la changer pour pas justement
que les étudiants soient sûres sur
comment on a dit comment sur les sites
sursollicités ouais parce qu'à ce moment
là ces étudiants là ne se présente pas
non plus au cercle à l'heure au stade
des premières nations du cam
non ce serait en fait
le cercle mais pas seulement c'est pas
seulement un cercle d utiliser un
secteur où beaucoup d'étudiants docteur
no 6 qui s'impliquent le oui je te dirai
en fait que kim a géré la majorité son
nom autochtone par ma connaissance la
majorité des gens qui fréquentent le
cirque son nom autochtone va et quelles
sont les réelles raisons pour le
fréquenter un intérêt soulève des
questions mais normalement est ce que
vous vous auriez préféré que ce soient
des autochtones qui le fréquentent ou
non petit tour en fait je suis jeune
avis que c'est ensemble qu'on va réussir
à changer les choses donc aux six comme
ce que je vois le genre on doit être
complice avec les mines ont adopté à
l'automne puis seule fin de les intégrer
dans le sexe pas seulement les
autochtones
oui toi maylis je dis toi maintenant à
manier la récente arrivée de ton côté
aussi mais toi pourquoi tu as choisi de
fréquenter le cercle alors quand est
arrivé à montréal
tu aurais pu faire comme d'autres
étudiants autochtones plaisir mais ça
m'intéresse pas moi je fais mes affaires
et c'est moi tant que personne je me
sens connectée avec mac os 10 gige à
partir d'une nation oui bien benzema qui
sont si mon ami faits qui m'ont vraiment
sollicité pour mettre au sec des
premières nations et les clubs comme ça
je me sens intéressé est à faire partie
du cercle mais si toutes les deux vous
vouliez convaincre d'autres étudiants
d'y participer vous leur diriez quoi
[Musique]
bein moi justement juge j'ai un poste à
l'uqam si je veillais l'accalmie ce cas
cela pour l'accueil et l'intégration des
autochtones à l'uqam ok c'est quoi le
muscat le salon nice car locale le cas
de star locale seulement pour les
autochtones c'est pour relaxer étudiés
des ordinateurs sur place et un
téléphone aussi un micro ondes et tout
ce qu'on a besoin pour accueillir des
autochtones décision oui c'est ça en
fait le nom qu'il avait avancée local
laitiers de la rencontre des étudiants
autochtones
ballard est passé c'est moi qui avais
ton post en fait donc avec la
conseillère à l'accueil à l'étude de la
conseillère à l'accueil et l'intégration
des étudiants autochtones à l'époque on
a voulu changer le monde
on a choisi une escorte qui vous dire où
en est ce qu'un mec parce qu'on trouvait
que ça représentait beaucoup la réalité
des étudiants autochtones qui migrent
vers le sud dans les centres urbains
pour retourner ensuite dans leur peau
dans leur connerie c'est ça oui oui je
m'en sers classe et associations
étudiantes le sont importantes justement
pour ça parce qu'elles permettent à des
étudiants qui arrivent de la plupart de
deux régions très éloignées finalement
de se rencontrer de partager des
difficultés aussi l'adaptation à
montréal c'est quand même pas rien quand
tu arrives de je sais pas où les coins
djetou bon peu est mort donc ça permet
ça se partage là ça enlève un peu de
stress on se donne des trucs je pense à
l'université laval ça n'existait pas
quand j'étais aux backstages ouvrir ma
dernière année de bac et on a vu quand
même une différence au niveau des gens
qui m'ont dit des étudiants autochtones
qui arrivait de régions éloignées qui
m'ont dit bon écoute si je n'avais pas
connu ce cercle là où cette association
étudiante autochtones le jeu posture que
je repasse à travers donc faut pas
minimiser l'importance de ses singles
non exactement là on va parler de choses
sérieuses on va parler de sous parce que
pour réussir à réaliser tout ça ça prend
de l'argent c'est dommage mais c'est le
nerf de la guerre
allons-y d'abord avec le cercle avec le
cercle est ce qu'on vous donne les
moyens de pouvoir être la présence sur
la place publique à l'uqam
ouais on ressent quand même un certain
montant de lincent panthères mais on
reçoit aussi beaucoup d'argent en fait
des autres associations
à l'uqam oui j'ai que l'afev nous donne
beaucoup souvent les sèche c'est quoi
cette semaine je crois si je me trompe
pas mais sinon qu'à la barre aussi
beaucoup avec le criaq sierra aussi j'ai
un groupe de recherche à l'uqam oui
exactement
ok donc et tout ça c'est suffisant pour
faire fonctionner le cercle ouais moi je
dirais que oui c'est suffisant mais
c'est pas beaucoup des fois oui ben je
sais pas comment auriez-vous des
priorités que vous n'êtes pas capables
d'atteindre ou de répondre finalement
parce que il ya un manque de financement
puis finalement vous vous faites
certaines activités culturelles mais
peut-être si on rêve le vraiment il ya
eu des choses que vous désiriez
désireriez phare je vous pouvez pas
parce que vous n'avez pas l'argent web
un maton faire venir des experts
culturelle des communautés pour qui
vient de partager comme wheeler
connaissant souvent on peut pas parce
que faut payer les frais transport pour
payer les frais d'hébergement ou sleepy
on oppose souvent l'argent pour ce non
plus je pense que steve le 2 en
organiser l'événement qui s'appelle
guérir par leurs pratiques afin que
plusieurs personnes qu'on ne peut plus
invité invité qu'on aurait avoué avoir
avec nous mais alors qu'il a kill qui
étaient là qui étaient présents ce
moment là pour cet événement là il y
avait jacques newashish y'avait
marie-claude mais aux ados de pierre et
roman on va chercher une maison de
maître en point et ont réussi à se
déplacer parce qu'ils habitent dans les
environs ou jacques je pense qu'il y
avait pas marre il ya quand même
quelques personnes qui ont réussi à se
déplacer mais vous auriez vu l'événement
un peu plus gros si vous aviez eu les
moyens de le faire exact dans ce cas là
je pense que particulièrement pis bon le
le coordonnateur historique du cpn uqam
gustavo qui l'a depuis quelques
décennies
je pense que lui une question de
montendre de montants d'argent mais
c'est surtout la question de la
pérennisation d'avoir un montant
récurrent pour pour rendre permanent
permanente ces activités-là notamment
une fois par mois il ya les soirées
arrêts clés de sa recule tueur du cpn
uqam au bar l'escalier c'est toujours
une chaque année une bataille pour
chercher et trouver le montant destiné à
faire ces soirées alors le grillage les
sert à montréal
différents groupes et side appuyé de
temps en temps les activités mais c'est
la pérennisation
oui il est question de la privatisation
c'est la vie de l'institution comme pour
le poste d'accueil
l'agente de liaison s'est il faut
pérenniser oui et vous de votre côté
alors avez vous les moyens de vos
actions je dirais qu on a
à force de bataille interne réussi à
dégager un montant qui est quand même
satisfaisant pour j'allais dire
travailler dans le sens d'une
autorisation de la recherche de
l'enseignement ce qui nous permet
d'inviter énormément de conférenciers
par exemple dans le cours d'introduction
au monde autochtone ce qui nous permet
de faire des activités avec le cpn uqam
ce qui nous permet d'amener les
étudiants sur le terrain puisque là
c'est un volet est extrêmement important
de travailler notamment que la
communauté de manawan et touristes
manawan et patrick mans a amené des
étudiants justement dans cet objectif de
sensibilisation aux réalités autochtones
donc travailler en partenariat pour
sortir des étudiants des bancs de
l'université
les leur faire vivre une expérience sur
un partenariat ça c'est bien important
de ne pas arriver à 60 étudiants dans la
communauté parce que ces conditions il
n'y a pas la bora s'est certes oui ça on
fait ça avec l'université de montréal et
avec luca toni en alternance chaque
année on travaille ensemble on s'aime
beaucoup finalement donc là on essaye et
puis il s'est pas suffisant il faut
aussi travailler du côté des étudiants
des étudiants autochtones sensibiliser
les étudiants d'un autochtone c'est
important mais il faut qu'on renforce et
qu'on ait les moyens de développer des
cours
alors isabelle a donné le cours
gouvernance des femmes autochtones avec
le service aux collectivités de l'uqam
mais il faut développer aussi pour que
les étudiants se sentent concernés marie
christine a suivi les cours acuna un
cours d'introduction au monde autochtone
ça ne l'intéresse pas forcément non j'ai
tout vu non c'est au canada elle se
tourne les pouces vraiment combat cessa
faut qu'on pense aux étudiants
autochtones
c'est ça aussi des colonisés le monde de
l'enseignement ce pas juste sensibiliser
c'est aussi former les étudiants
autochtones des communautés est prêt il
ya des groupes qui le font allez dans
les communautés aussi donner un
enseignement c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que dans un programme
comme études autochtones
il faut absolument être en contact avec
une communauté autochtone au minimum je
te cela passe à côté
je peux le dire parce que j'ai fait tout
un certificat tout le mélange puis il y
avait plusieurs allochtone puis et tous
qui connaissait c'était wendat qui parce
que c'était coller sur l'université
laval
mais quand on parlait aussi de
décolonisation de l'enseignement aux
autochtones dans mon cours gouvernance
autochtones au féminin ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tout de suite cet
effet en partenariat avec ferme
autochtones du québec et tout de suite
vivienne oui mais voilà donc ce qu'elle
dit c'est que c'était important d'avoir
aussi des moments où on pouvait échanger
entre femmes c'est un cours qui est
suivi seulement par des femmes et qu'on
garde un petit groupe on est douze
femmes et avoir des cercles de partage
on peut échanger on peut pleurer on peut
rire on peut donc seul ça fait partie
aussi de l'enseignement autochtone de la
décolonisation de la manière de faire
l'enseignement une partie théorique bien
sûr mais à présent ils échangent en
discutons chacun des expériences comme
autochtone qui proviennent de
communautés différentes d 'argent
différemment et caetera et on met tous
en commun et c'est vraiment gagnant à la
fin alors dans un monde idéal le milieu
universitaire décoloniser
ça serait quoi qui a envie de se lancer
en premier
laurent je vois réagir beaucoup rejouer
je prends le point de vue de
l'institution s'est on a parlé de rendre
les contenus
culturellement pertinents ça passe
évidemment par l'engagement important de
profs autochtone à l'université c'est un
collègue qui me faisait remarquer
récemment que si on prend juste une
question chiffres évidemment c'est comme
ça dans la réalité mais si on prend un
chiffre si la population autochtone
totale du canada représente que 4 points
9 % de la population totale
oui ok à l'uqam on devrait actuellement
avoir 56 prof autochtone il y en a eu
quatre points 9 % week-end à 1155 prof à
l'uqam avoir 50
oui oui là je me fie sur son calcul
c'est lui qui m'a dit ça je vais pas
quelqu'un qui peut vérifier ok donc 56
prof
ok actuellement on en a deux oui bon on
est loin du coup c'est pas l'uqam
particulièrement c'est le même look
était concordia dans l'est un peu plus
et rendu un peu plus loin je pense
qu'une dizaine mais moi un monde idéal
c'est justement de pouvoir favoriser
vraiment au niveau des études
supérieures
la formation des étudiants autochtones
au delà du bac donc maîtrise doctorat
avec des profs autochtone mais ça se
fait pas d'un coup de machette on
n'engage pas un prof autochtones comme
ça du jour au lendemain il faut réformer
totalement les cycles supérieurs
revoir les conditions d'admissibilité il
faut tout changer ça en train d'admirer
mais c'est pas que je rendrai la lie
encore beaucoup de travail de ré monde
idéal pour vous isabelle j'ai lu quelque
chose cette semaine que j'ai trouvé
extrêmement intéressant la
décolonisation c'est c'est non pas
seulement d'avoir un siège à la table
avec les autres mais c'est carrément de
briser la table 2
il de faire un feu avec pour fer
souhaite loggia laquelle on va éviter de
londres je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant c'est c'est d'aller au delà
de juste oui c'est important les
autochtones les affaires autochtones à
l'uqam dans les universités mais c'est
vraiment de réformer le système au
complet ça se fait pas du jour au
lendemain ils disent non un monde idéal
rapidement le temps passe et une idée de
la question là ce serait de collaborer
avec lui les électeurs aussi pique aussi
oui c'est vrai que ce serait le fun qui
a du sens 550 tonnes
c'est ça serait le fun aussi d'avoir
leurs connaissances plutôt qu'ils nous
transmettent aussi joué dans un monde
idéal où vivent les marie-christine pas
gérer dans le même sens aussi c'est vrai
que la rai me pose beaucoup pour
continuer à maîtrise a vraiment pas mais
je pense que ça serait d'avoir de plus
en plus d'enseignants autochtone dans
les institutions mais pour l'instant
c'est oui ça serait mon premier objectif
voilà on va espérer que vos voeux se
réalisent alors merci à tous les quatre
je vais vous présenter comme il faut
pour terminer pour qu'on se rappelle
bien qui vous êtes maylis flamand
étudiante à l'uqam en étude critique des
sexualités
un jour viendra nous expliquer les
intrigants merci laurent jérôme
professeur à l'uqam anthropologue
directeur de la revue de recherche
amérindienne du québec amérindienne
fondateur et co responsable des
programmes en études autochtones donc à
l'uqam
merci beaucoup marie cécile petit coup
et étudiantes donc en 3e année mais
également président du cercle des
premières nations de l'uqam
merci et isabelle picard notre
chroniqueuse mais également chargé de
cours à l'université du québec à
montréal
merci à tous les quatre
et j'espère que tout ce que vous nous
avez dit aujourd'hui aura été entendu et
bien retenu merci et merci à vous tous
d'avoir encore une fois été présents
cette semaine on se retrouve vendredi
prochain sur ce plateau au revoir
[Musique]